das amerikanische volk hat jetzt
erfahren was das größte versagen
jeglicher präsidenten regierung in
unserem lande ist und hier die tatsache
dazu 210.000 menschen sind gestorben in
unserem land in den letzten monaten mehr
als sieben millionen haben sich mit dem
virus angesteckt eins von fünf
unternehmen musste schließen
arbeiter mitarbeiter die an vorderster
front arbeiten die sich quasi auf opfern
wir haben mehr als 30 millionen menschen
in den letzten sieben monaten
arbeitslosenhilfe beantragen muss und
jetzt folgendes am 28 januar wurden der
vize premier unter präsident informiert
über die arf dieser pandemie ihnen wurde
gesagt dass sie tödlich verläuft
letztendlich das über die luft
übertragen wird dass es auch junge
menschen treffen kann und dass man sich
ansteckt weil es eben über die luft
übertragen wird und sie wussten was
passierte und sie haben es ihnen nicht
gesagt
unser land unser volk gehen durch
schwierige zeit nehmen möchte dass der
amerikanerinnen und amerikaner dies
wissen vom allerersten tag hat präsident
gesagt die gesundheit wie ganz zuoberst
die die ersten fälle waren kamen aus
china er hat mir wird dann als jeder
andere amerikanische präsident erbt alle
den ganzen reiseverkehr nach china in
die zweitgrößte volkswirtschaft
eingestellt die senatorin joe biden war
gegen diesen beschluss
er hat gesagt er sei ausländerfeindlich
und hysterisch ich habe die
arbeitsgruppe geleitet am weißen haus
und allein dieser beschluss hat uns
wertvollste zeit eingebracht und die
grössten mobilisierung der nation seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg mit schuh staaten
und hat uns hunderttausende von leben
gerettet bewahrt
zum thema wirtschaft glaube ich könnte
der unterschied nicht grundlegender
seien zwischen donald trump und dabei
ist der meinung dass man die gesundheit
die stärke der amerikanischen wirtschaft
danach bemisst wie gesund und wie stark
der amerikanischen arbeitnehmer sind und
die amerikanischen familien auf der
anderen seite haben sie doch nur derbe
misst die stärke der wirtschaft danach
wie reicht die leute sind oder wie es
den reichen geht vielmehr deswegen hatte
eine steuergesetzgebung erlassen
wo die top 1 prozent und die
großunternehmen in amerikaner in amerika
vorteile rausziehen 1 3 billionen dollar
defizit bleibt der übrigen dafür muss
das amerikanische volk zahlen
bevor ich ins amt kam hat amerika die
schlimmste wirtschaftskrise seit der
großen depression wurde reguliert da
jetzt verlassen wenn die steuern gesenkt
und einfach quer beet unabhängig davon
der senatorin herrlich sagt die
durchschnittsfamilie amerika hat 2000
dollar steuern weniger gezahlt um mit
den lohnerhöhung ließ gegebener
vorwiegend für arbeit hat das
familieneinkommen sich im jahr um 45
dollar erhöht
am ersten tag wird joe biden die steuern
erheben bürger finde ich ganz
bemerkenswert biden will alles
zurückdrehen während land für die
arbeitsplätze und die arbeit in amerika
er kämpft
täuschen wir uns nicht die amerikanische
wirtschaft das amerikanische comeback
läuft und es steht auf eurem stimmzettel
vier jahre weitere jahre für dann wenn
das der größte wirtschaftsaufschwung
ja ich glaube in der debatte letzte
woche haben wir genug davon gesehen und
hier heute soll es ja mal um fakten und
tatsachen gehen tatsache ist
bei irgendjemandem der weniger 40 reden
auf ich denke dir die steuersenkung von
trump zurück sehen und sie sprechen von
wahrheit der zweimal letzte woche gesagt
dass er die steuersenkung und rückgängig
machen will
steuersenkung die den durchschnittlichen
arbeit in den usa jedes jahr 2000 dollar
kosten
bausenatorin bitter sind ganz und gar
nicht oder will er das nur teilweise
zurück wenn die mich vielleicht ausreden
lassen wollen dann können wir
tatsächlich konversationen führen
joe biden wird keine steuern erhöhen
für jemand der weniger als 4000 dollar
im jahr verdient das hat er sehr klar
gesagt was den klimawandel angeht das
klima wandelt sich punkt ist nur der
revidierbar warum und was machen wir da
gegen präsident hat klar gemacht
er wird weiter den wissenschaftlern zu
hören beiden und harry soll uns
zurückwerfen in die zeiten des pariser
klimaabkommens die haben diesen green
new deal vorgeschlagen der wird die
energie teurer machen für jede einzelne
familien den usa reden wir doch mal
darüber wer bereit ist unser land über
die nächsten jahre durch das so führen
was eine existenzielle bedrohung für uns
menschen ist so sagt investieren in
erneuerbare energien
wir werden millionen jobs schaffen wir
werden null emission bis zum jahre 2050
schaffen 15
so hat dazu plant die regierung die
redet viel aber im grunde sind das
schritte zurück und nicht nach vorne
wir werden auch natürlich gerne wieder
eines klimaabkommen eintreten und
menschen landesweit menschen jeglicher
rasse jeglichen alters jeglichen
geschlechts die sich gegenseitig nicht
kannten sind schulter an schulter arm in
arm marschiert haben erkämpft
protestiert damit wir endlich dieses
ideal von gleichheit vor dem gesetz
erreichen
ich war teil dieses friedlichen protest
und ich glaube ganz fest dass zunächst
mal eben niemals gewalt gutheißen werden
aber dass wir immer kämpfen werden
müssen
für die werte die wir hochhalten
einschließlich den kampf unsere ideale
und das haben joe biden und ich zu
diesem thema gesagt widerfahren ist und
es wird gerechtigkeit geschehen
aber das ist doch keine entschuldigung
für aufruhr und plünderung wie zynismus
nachher kamen wir können
kontrovers diskutieren auch sie
natürlich heute abend hier auf der bühne
ab wenn die schon vorbei ist dann stehen
wir als amerikaner beieinander hat schon
lange lange unbearbeitet
parteiübergreifend und genau das wird ja
auch als präsident fortsetzen
er hat eine lange historie dass er den
menschen zu etwas besserem bringt das
affäre würde kämpft sie müssen jones
persönliche geschichte kennen um zu
wissen er hat schmerz bekannt er hat
gelitten er hat auch liebe erfahren
[Musik]